hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain
an american drama and fiction movie
called looks that kill
the movie starts by showing a teenage
boy whose face is wrapped in bandages
and uses glasses and a hat to cover his
entire head his name is max
he is accompanied by his parents to do
therapy with dr clement he says that he
has a disorder that lies in his face
which is too handsome so that everyone
who sees his face immediately dies as
well as the doctor who helped max's
delivery also died after seeing max's
handsome face
when max was two years old his family
decided to move out of a city that is
not inhabited by many people dr clement
doesn't believe max instead he thinks
that max is depressed because of his
past
a few moments later the doctor dies
after seeing max's face
then the police come and ask max's
parents for information stating that the
cause of death from the doctor was due
to a heart attack but the cause is still
unknown to them in the end max and his
parents are allowed to go home by the
police
at night his parents invite max's only
friend named danny to have dinner
together at their house
while eating his father tells danny to
take him out and find other friends but
he refuses because he doesn't want to
kill other people with his face again
after that max asks danny to hit his
face with a brick but danny initially
refuses
until one time max intentionally drops
danny's cell phone making him angry so
he hits max in the face using the brick
the next day max and his mother go to a
hospital to treat his nose due to being
hit by danny last night there he meets a
woman the same age as him named alex who
is waiting in line two they have time to
get acquainted with each other while
waiting for their respective cues when
he gets home danny suddenly returns to
his house to apologize for his action
last night by inviting max to meet
another woman named erica at a
restaurant at the restaurant erica
firstly thinks that she is going to date
danny but in fact he only sets her up
with max
after danny leaves them a bad guy craig
unexpectedly interrupts their date as
max accidentally drops his drink in
front of them craig wipes the table
using max's face which is covered in
bandages causing erica to leave him
alone
the next morning he plans to jump into
the river to end his life but alex
happens to pass by there to prevent him
from committing suicide
after that she asks him to go to a
nursing home and they spend time
together there after returning home max
tells danny about his experience with
alex the next day he decides to wait
again for alex near the bridge
shortly after she actually comes there
and max invites her to play together at
his house they tell the truth about each
other's ailments starting with max
telling about the abnormality on his
face and alex telling him that she has a
rare cardiovascular disease that makes
her allergic to endorphins endorphins
are hormones that are caused by certain
feelings such as sadness or happiness so
that when alex feels these feelings it
can cause inflammation which causes her
heart to swell and the disease gets
worse every day
automatically she has never felt sad or
happy since childhood and that is very
sad for her
after the conversation they decide to go
to the cinema together and get drunk
they end up in max's room and get
carried away almost kissing however this
is thwarted by the appearance of his
parents there they introduce a woman
named yusen who is an exchange student
she will stay with them for a few days
one day when they go camping something
happens when max kisses alex which
triggers her endorphins causing her to
have an inflamed heart and has to be
rushed to the hospital luckily she still
can be saved
another day alex invites max to visit
one of her friends rose who is dying at
the hospital but the sad feeling for
rose actually makes alex's condition
worse and causes her to have a nosebleed
due to the endorphins
max who can't bear to see rose in pain
deliberately removes his bandage to make
her die faster using his deadly face
later max is sad because alex suddenly
walks away from him it turns out that
she stays away from him because her
illness is getting worse as an apology
she invites him to a party that night
she also brings a mask for him and they
seem to be happy at the party even
though on the other hand they are
suffering because of their respective
illnesses alex suddenly has another
nosebleed at the party but she pretends
she wants to go to the toilet when max
is alone and approached by danny and his
girlfriend craig mischievously takes off
max's mask causing danny's girlfriend to
die
soon the police arrest him and the
medics take alex to the hospital
fortunately he is only temporarily
detained and allowed to go home due to
lack of evidence again
he visits alex straightaway who was
already in the hospital
there she tells her condition where
since childhood the doctors estimated
that she would survive until the age of
16 but strangely until today at the age
of 17 she still survives the disease and
it's a miracle for her
in fact before she met max she had never
been happy because it is known
beforehand that if she feels happy or
sad then the disease recurred with all
the suffering she has gone through she
sadly asks him to take off his bandages
so she can die faster without feeling
pain anymore instead max chooses to
scold her and leaves her alone
at his house he desperately hits his
face again with a brick
since then he never picks up alex's
phone and he meets danny to ask him for
advice
after being given some wise advice
obtained from captions on social media
he agrees and goes back to meet alex at
the hospital she says that she loves him
very much and gives max a few words
max eventually can't bear to see her
dying and he decides to slowly remove
his bandage so that she can die faster
without feeling any pain surprisingly
his deadly face doesn't work on alex and
instead she instantaneously dies from
the illness she has been suffering from
all this time
after alex's death he continues his
therapy in the case of danny's
girlfriend's death is closed because she
died of an overdose besides then he
becomes an angel of death granting
euthanasia to all who request it it can
be concluded that these people die not
because they see max's deadly face but
because of a lack of sincerity and
perfection of love
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching